Global News at the beginning you were
talking about the transmission levels
are starting to improve and there's good
indication of that and you also said the
enfs was saying that hospitalization
should start stabilizing within the next
couple of weeks so if the indicators are
going in the right direction why are you
requiring The Mask mandate to be
extended until mid-may if the signs are
looking promising yeah it's because
those signs are expected I mean those
numbers are expected right now there are
signs that it's moving down as a
transmission but not necessarily on the
hospital situation so we have to be
careful with those numbers because we're
just coming out from an Easter period of
konji of release and the data that we
we're using might be uncertain so we we
would prefer to keep the the the looking
they're careful looking at the numbers
for a few days we've said that we've
recommended it because there is still a
real pandemic situation right now uh in
the Quebec it is it seems to be not as
worse that it was a week ago but it's
still very heavy so and the the data
coming from sirano uh is still showing
numbers of over 30 to 50 000 person per
day so it's still really active we have
to be careful with that and if the
numbers are really showing a drop then
we can revise our recommendation for the
to the government concerning the wearing
the obligation of the Mask wearing thank
you next question Lauren McCallum CBC
yes thank you for taking my question I I
have a question about the flu you said
that it's on the rise in English can you
tell us a little bit more about uh the
conflict or the um imposition this poses
on the hospital system and what can
people do to avoid getting it
well the the best first of all the flu
is still moving up we have numbers
showing that it's in progression last
week we estimated that it was a low
level of of contamination it's not a
moderate one it would not be a surprise
for us that will get intensify over the
next few days or weeks and with that in
mind we We wish all the persons to be
careful and especially for the one that
are at risk of developing
issues that are not uh that we would not
like them to have side like
hospitalization or really bad situation
for for their
influenza diseases and with that in mind
we certainly agreed that the measures
are are similar from the one to Kevin 19
so wearing masks is a good option for
that it's not it should not be mandatory
for an influenza situation it's more
related to the covet situation right now
but they have to be careful on the side
of the hospital I would like to leave my
colleague doctor or partner to
answer more so the other thing we
mentioned was that it's the first time
since the beginning pandemic that we
have both
um covid as well as influenza
um really at the same time uh in in
people as Dr wallow mentioned uh both
um both conditions have very much
overlapping symptoms and both are being
seen in the emergency rooms and are
causing a additional strain on the
emergency rooms
and as Dr boloma also mentioned uh the
the the in terms of staying home uh uh
and
um and not being out and about when one
has these symptoms are the same for uh
for for both conditions but it is the
first time in two years that we're
seeing both of them active at the same
time
thank you next question Matt Grillo CTV
hey good afternoon a question for Dr
bualo
um you know we see the third dose rate
uh vaccination rate is it's considerably
lower than the first two
in some months from now down the road
do you worry at all that the fourth dose
perhaps will be even lower considerably
lower than than the third dose
well the first thing is that yes for the
first two doses it was uh clearly an
uptake really uh widespread throughout
the population it was great for that and
most of the people have been well
protected against the the virus and
especially for Delta situation in the
recent month
having had two doses is still something
that is quite good but not as good as
three Doses and we have to follow the
the science with that and recommend it
to be taken what we observed is also
that more than 87 percent of the
population over 60 is well protected
with the third dose of the people that
are really at risk right now they are
not the only one but really at risk for
the sad progression of the baa2 are well
vaccinated so are we concerned about the
progression of the willingness or the um
the interest of the population over
vaccination yes we're all always worried
about that throughout the world but in
in our experience in Quebec it is we
have one of the best response from the
population to take the those Innovations
and benefit from it which is great so we
expect that there will be a follow-up on
this willingness and with good advisors
and especially if we're confronted to a
new race eventually of the covid
situation with that variant or other we
we are really confident that the people
will follow it and will prevent
themselves to develop very sad issues
with that
Canadian press
uh hi Dr Polo I also in keeping with the
vaccination question I wonder do you
know
do you know the fourth dose is doing
here in Quebec and also do you have any
um data on whether or not the people
that were very concerned about using um
mRNA vaccines if novovax has changed
anything for us here in the province
I will answer for the new events first
we have some data that a few hundreds of
people have already benefited from the
novavax opportunity to be vaccinated
because as you may know some of them
some of the people were reluctant to use
the iron message
potential of vaccination which was still
very good so with with that new tool of
novovax we think that we're reaching for
other people that were just waiting for
it to arrive so that's great
concerning the the other question
related to the four dose is it's moving
very well Mr Perry was with me who's the
deputy Minister assistant Deputy
minister in charge of that was with me
earlier today and was confirming that
just yesterday we had more than 40 000
people that have received their doses
mostly fourth those so should they be in
in long-term care unit or uh arpia or or
citizens that are at home they are
benefiting from it so we we do not have
the numbers completed over the four four
dozers but it's it's going well
thank you next question Caitlin Thomas
Montreal Gazette
question is for Dr Willow
is mandate in schools if you're
extending it everywhere else until the
middle of May
yeah well it's still mandated in school
but not necessarily when the children
are the students and children in fact
are in the classroom so we it is still
mandatory during their walking around in
in every other places that they they're
they're going
we made analysis of the risk and the
benefit of wearing masks inside the
school inside this classrooms and was
not seen as relevant enough to to
introduce it again as mandatory was
great for for the the past I mean the
people that suggested it was uh were
working very seriously but right now
with the data we observe it's not
necessary and and by the way the
situation in most of the schools of
Quebec is globally uh moving down so
it's the the numbers of cases I've not
reached the one that we had in in
January for the students and it's still
sit I mean for the data of last week
compared the week before and those of
this week it's moving down which is
great for the students
we
um
[Music]
I don't know foreign
foreign
Madame Cousino voir
we disagree here today
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
five
next question Lauren McCallum CBC
thank you adjust Dr Polo if you can tell
us in English we're looking at the Ines
figures the projections from today it
would appear that there is it going to
be a dip in other words looks like we've
hit the peak of the sixth wave but
Easter hasn't been factored in yet can
you tell us have we hit the sixth way
the peak of the sixth wave and what
impact will Easter have
well I know the methodology of inessa
quite well I was the CEO and president
of this organization until recently
three months ago and we had this
discussion with the uh the the CEO of
yes this morning and the expert Dr Mike
vinigiri and as as you may have heard
before inesis those projections are
mathematical ones and made very
carefully with a lot of methodology
um that that will figure if it continues
that way then it will be that in two
weeks but continues that way it's still
something that we're not sure about
because we only have two data from this
week during the weekends it was very low
and it not it should not be a bias or
confusion
measures that will
um that will figure that this low
lowering will will still be there so it
with with few more days we'll be more
confident on that but there is a strong
hope that will get there and normally is
not the Ines is not missing the call and
which is fortunate is that as Dr
opaterny said there is about 2 400 maybe
will reach 2005 in a few days but it
should not get really more than that and
on the uh Intensive Care Unit it's still
around or less than 100 Beds which is
great right now and Dr patani said
earlier that only five percent of the
cases are moving to the Intensive Care
Unit which is really different from the
other ways and which is great for the
Yale system because it really
challenging everywhere in the hospital
but especially in the Intensive Care
Unit
thank you next and very last question
please all right team sergeant again Dr
bolo just to follow up on what my
colleague was asking earlier about the
vaccination rates especially for the
third dose when you look at the numbers
of the young adults 18 to 39 year olds
the percentage is still very low it's
around 38 percent it's been like that
for quite some time why do you think it
is so low for that young adults to get
that third dose and what needs to be
done about it well it's most probably
related to the fact that they are not
very afraid from this ba2
situation and the a lot of them feels in
fact that they are sufficiently immune
to get through an infection of coffee
the other thing is that there's a lot of
them that that's been infected with
kavid and namely amicron and now with
bhu so with that and especially with the
situation of a micron where it reached a
lot of them
um they are certainly most of them will
say that well I'm now boosted with the
natural infection which is fairly true
for that but after three four months it
will be more than than okay to get the
advantages of the turtle so we're
insisting on that but it's their choices
but we expect them to feel less
protected in the near future when if
there will there will be another wave
coming let's say later this year much
much later this year then I think that
they will agree to get vaccinated
foreign